turning overseas it's been 11 days now
since two earthquakes devastated
Southern turkey and Northern Syria 11
days and yet Rescuers are still finding
survivors in the rubble that is the good
news however the death toll is now 41
000 more so in fact and still rising and
also many survivors are in Desperate
Straits themselves as rescue efforts
turn into a recovery and clearing
operation MTS tyab is in Northern Syria
for us talking to some people who have
their lives but seem to have lost nearly
everything else
this was once home to over a thousand
people as many as 800 of them died right
here so this this was your home
is one of the few survivors he tells us
how he was trapped under the rubble with
his wife and three children for more
than 22 hours I found a big rock and I
hit it as hard as I could
you just bang
Al marawi says we saw a light and my
kids started shouting daddy daddy a
light
this video shows the moment Al maharawi
and his kids were all saved
a rare glimmer of hope and rebel held
Syria already scarred from a decade-long
civil war
but this unrelenting disaster continues
to bring even more death
it's now a Race Against Time to help the
living families displaced by the Quake
are now Sheltering intents in this Olive
Grove the response to the disaster in
Syria continues to be catastrophically
slow president Bashar al-assad still
controls most borders and how much Aid
can come into the country
Western governments including the U.S
are wary of working with the regime it's
sanctioned a regime which oversaw the
killings of hundreds of thousands of
civilians Assad has agreed to open two
land routes through turkey for Aid
deliveries after immense pressure from
the U.N for Mustafa al-marawi it's all
too much you've lost so much
what will you do now
I have no hope left he says I sometimes
think it would have been better if I
stayed under the rubble
for CBS mornings I'm imtiaz tayab and
rebel-held Northern Syria
that's so disheartening to hear him say
that but I can also understand why he
may feel that way you look at these
little faces that are pulled out it's
amazing Tony's you said 11 days and
they're still pulling survivors that's
why you can't give up hope yeah and
there's the thrill of the rescue but
then the shock of seeing your
surroundings your town is not what it
was and that's it you know immediately
you think oh what a miracle they're
saving lives pulling people from the
rubble but then immediately it's reality
it's gonna be a long journey back to
normalcy there oh man for everybody